so I've actually started a number of
businesses in my career
some 28 currently but when I was about
16 I started building websites and
that's how I put myself through school I
went to Duke with a degree in electrical
engineering computer science computer
engineering and then two to Princeton
and during that time when I was building
websites and and putting myself through
school I was sort of commingling my
personal my business finances so I was
using quicken and Microsoft money since
I was about well 16 or 17 years old so
it's been almost 10 years or so and I
was pretty religious about it I would
manage my my finances as it were every
Sunday afternoon for about an hour each
Sunday made sure all of my accounts
would balance and then I was involved in
another startup where I was working 80
to 100 hours a week and I didn't open
Quicken for probably five months or so
and the problem with a desktop tool is
if you don't open it up it's not
updating your finances it's not pulling
in the information and once I I did that
it downloaded about 500 transactions and
they were all uncatted and it asked me
to reconcile all of my account balances
and it just seemed very tedious like why
would you want to balance a checkbook in
in this modern day and then I decided
there's got to be a better way an easier
way a faster way to manage your finances
and spend an hour every Sunday afternoon
doing it I want a tool where people can
get in and out in five minutes a week or
less and that takes like 10 minutes to
set up instead of an hour to set up and
that was the genesis of mint the the
first thing that I did was come up with
a categorization algorithm so that
instead of seeing a big pie chart where
most of the things are on categorized
this algorithm knows that Safeway is a
grocery store and Starbucks is a coffee
shop and it's smart it actually knows
about 20 million US merchants and then I
realize well that's a nice feature but
it's not a business and so if the user
knows where their money's going that's
great because they spend less time they
can set budgets they can see a nice pie
chart of their spending but as a company
it means we know where their money is
going and we can help them out we can
find better prices on the things that
they buy most like you spend $180 on
phone TV and Internet you could bundle
it together you have twenty thousand
dollars in an old checking account that
you open when you were seventeen and
it's just lying around not earning the
interest you're paying also fees on it
there's a better offer out there and so
mints business model became will go for
free and then we'll find these savings
opportunities for you there better
interest rate on your credit cards when
should you consolidate your student
loans when does it mathematically make
sense to refinance your mortgage and min
figures all that stuff out for you
well between the time that I created the
alpha version and we actually launched
it was about a year and I did build up a
team so I got financing and got some
more engineers and some real
professionals working on this but the
marketing plan was whatever we can do
basically for cheap or for free so
probably nine months before the product
even launched we started a blog a
personal finance blog and we had some of
our own content so we did this thing
that we called trainwreck Tuesdays it
was like people's worst financial
disaster and somehow reading about other
people's financial mistakes makes you
feel better about you know the mistakes
that you've made or like oh other people
really don't get it either
and then we did sort of a what's in your
wallet we would talk to either Silicon
Valley sort of tech celebrities or
personal finance bloggers and ask them
what credit cards do you carry what
brokerage accounts do you have why did
you choose these and that was an
interesting segment but most of our
content came from other personal finance
bloggers and we would just simply cross
link back to their site we got a lot of
free content and so by the time we
launched we had more traffic to our
personal finance blog than our
competitors who had beat us to the
market who had launched before us
actually had to their entire websites
and then we added you know a send us
your email we'll put you on the beta
because we're building demand for nine
months and we got about twenty thirty
thousand emails during that period which
was too many we couldn't let that many
people in all at once so we actually
said okay we'll give you special access
to to the beta if you put up a little
badge on your blog or your Facebook page
or wherever that says I want mint it's a
very small little badge and then we
looked at all the people who have those
embedded and what that did was it gave
people sort of exclusive VIP access sort
of like you know the velvet rope
treatment at a club but it got us free
advertising on 600 different blog
and not only the free advertising in
some sense we got the boost in search
engine ranking because Google actually
looks at how many people are linking to
your site in order to determine your
relevancy and your popularity and so the
more people who are links to your site
higher its PageRank and the better
you're going to do when people search
for things like personal finance tool or
budgeting software or whatever it may be